[Music]
mr. Justin Bieber has had an amazing
week he announced the stadium tour he
was nominated for some Grammy Awards can
you walk us through his head space right
now I think he and all of us are just
really pleased to be acknowledged I
think first and foremost who he's become
as a young man is something I'm the most
proud of and no nomination or award is
gonna change that
he's always under a lot of pressure
growing up in a time of social media and
spotlight and how he's handled himself
and come out at all and the young man
he's become I'm incredibly proud of that
and I think for his peers in the
artistic community to acknowledge that
with an ala New Year nomination and song
in the air nomination is incredibly
rewarding but it's it's secondary to his
character I gotta ask you Kanye West
eight Grammy nominations how is he doing
he's a fantastic individual and I am
blessed to call him my friend and he's
really great congratulations also to you
you welcomed your second son are you
sleeping
no I'm not sleeping at all he's a little
over a week old and he and his older
brother and mom are incredible and I'm
incredibly blessed Jagger handling all
of it he is loving being a big brother
yeah he's super super sweet I'm actually
very very proud of him you've been
working with make-a-wish for years why
is this cause so important to you I just
like the work that they do i I think the
opportunity to give a kid and something
special when they're fighting something
so hard it's some of the most amazing
things I've seen have been not only the
kids with their siblings you know their
siblings give up so much for the
happiness of their brother or sister and
that's just an incredible thing to watch
you